zugeschaltet aus münster ist uns jetzt
professor thomas sternberg präsident des
zentralkomitees der deutschen katholiken
zdk ich grüße sie nach münster nach
westfalen der professor sternberg wir
müssen beginnen beim guten morgen wir
müssen beginnen beim vertrauensverlust
es gab zeiten anfang dieses jahres da
ist der server die website des
amtsgerichts köln zusammengebrochen weil
zu viele menschen gleichzeitig aus der
kirche austreten wollen und meinen
termin ersucht haben kann dieses zweite
gutachten so einen trend jetzt stoppen
das weiß ich nicht zumal die verärgerung
im märz bis zum kölner der ganze reihe
von gründen haben das ist natürlich vor
allen dingen ein kommunikations desaster
was es da gegeben hat ob dieses erste
gutachten und wirklich veröffentlichungs
fähig war nicht das kann ich gar nicht
beurteilen das haben juristen
empfohlenes nicht zu verurteilen aber
wie damit umgegangen worden ist
das war ja und 40 gesang und
professionell das war ein desaster
und das hat zu diesem großen das hat
diesen großen vertrauensverlust noch
bestärkt ich hoffe dass es gelingen wird
hier wieder vertrauen auch bei den
eigenen gläubigen zurückzugewinnen also
die man jetzt wirklich lückenlose
transparenz macht er transparenz ist
jetzt das neue stichwort hinter dem sich
alle versammeln wollen auch kardinal
woelki der massiv in der kritik steht
sie haben ihn auch öffentlich schon in
der vergangenheit recht offen kritisiert
und scharf sie haben das handling der
affäre durch wirke als katastrophal
bezeichnet kann er im amt bleiben
die frage nach rücktritten will ich gar
nicht hier stellen und beantworten ich
habe den eindruck ein rücktritt wäre
notwendig ist notwendig da muss ja auch
gezogen werden solche konsequenzen sind
richtig nur man sollte sich davor hüten
zu glauben dass sein rücktritt probleme
lösen würde
das problem muss jetzt angegangen werden
auch auf andere weise zum beispiel in
der konsequenten inbetriebnahme der
unabhängigen kommission für die
aufarbeitung sowie diese kommissionen
im letzten jahr von der
bischofskonferenz mit dem unabhängigen
beauftragten röhrig beschlossen worden
sind ja und der doch professor sternberg
muss man nachfragen bei all dem was sie
vorher gesagt haben dem wunsch nach
transparenz und aufklärung kann er mit
aktuell und in der vergangenheit
agierenden personen glaubwürdig
passieren selbst wenn also jetzt dieses
gutachten ihn vielleicht juristisch frei
spricht kann er ist moralisch noch zu
halten sind eine fülle von fragen die
dahinterstehen ich meine strafrechtlich
ist das ganze sowieso bei den
staatsanwaltschaften alle
nordrhein-westfälischen bistümer haben
ihre unterlagen der staatsanwaltschaft
übergeben auch kerker dass jetzt sofort
gemacht
ich glaube staatsanwaltschaftlich ist
das nicht das thema hier das wird
selbstverständlich strafrechtlich
geprüft es geht ja vor allen dingen um
kirchenrechtliche kirchenrechtliche
vergehen das muss geprüft werden
das haben die sich auch geprüft und wie
gesagt auch rücktritte müssen dann
möglich sein nur rücktritte und
entlassungen sind spektakulär aber sind
keine lösung des problems wichtig sind
mir präventionsarbeit intensivieren noch
intensivieren und die empathie mit den
betroffenen dass die betroffenen zu wort
kommen dass sie wirklich ihre sich
äußern beteiligen können auch einen
aufarbeitungsprozess dass ihnen
gerechtigkeit zuteil wird das scheint
mir im moment das wichtigste sein und
natürlich auch die lückenlose
darstellung dessen was war denn es ist
nach wie vor ein riesiges entsetzen
darüber dass auch im raum der kirche
nicht nur in anderen fällen der
gesellschaft auch im raum der kirche und
gerade sogar und erklären kann
missbrauchs geschehen möglich war in den
letzten vierzig fünfzig jahren also
professor sternberg ich neben ihren
vorschlag auf reden wir etwas intensiver
noch über aufarbeitungen über auch frage
von entschädigungen
sie haben mehr oder weniger angedeutet
es hat ein versagen der strukturen
gegeben was muss sich da ändern was kann
sich da ändern ist ein schwerfälliges
gebilde
ja ich glaube dass generell der umgang
mit sexualisierter gewalt heute ein ganz
anderer ist und auch sein muss man
blickt heute selbstverständlich stärker
auf die betroffenen betroffenen müssen
im mittelpunkt dieser fragen stehen
nicht die täter und der täterschutz und
ist eine frage die nicht nur klerikern
verhandelt sie geht auch uns selber auch
als laien an auch als gemeinden wie
haben wir eigentlich weg gesehen wie
haben wir auch in unseren verbänden und
vereinen so etwas geduldet und toleriert
in ganz vielfältiger weise was ist an
missbrauch geschehen auch in verbänden
vereinigungen bei uns bei laien wir
dürfen das problem nicht alleine auf die
kleriker frage reduzieren
und ich glaube da hat es gerade durch
diese große erschütterung der seit dem
jahr 2010 in deutschland und schon
vorher weltweit die diese
erschütterungen dass auch kleriker
missbraucht und gemacht haben
durch diese erschütterung hat es eine
neubewertung und eine neue sensibilität
für die frage gegeben und das muss
deutlich weiter gehen
wir werden uns sehr viel intensiver mit
diesen fragen beschäftigen müssen er
professor standard nun haben sie
angesprochen die opfer das muss
sozusagen auch transparenz seien aber
auch offen und glaubwürdig
strafrechtliche wege sind sehr
langwierig es geht ja auch um die frage
von entschädigungen schweben in der
konkrete summen vor
da gibt es ja jetzt eine ganz gute
regelung denke ich dass die
bischofskonferenz gesagt hat wir halten
uns bei diesen regelungen an das was im
deutschen strafrecht üblich ist und zwar
an die oberen grenzen
ich bin teilweise schockiert wie gering
da die summen ausfallen hier in münster
ist gerade bei diesen unfassliche
verbrechen der gerade zur vermietung
eines elfjährigen jungen 1 1 geld von
20.000 euro
im urteil zugestanden worden dh die
summe sehr sehr gering aber in
deutschland sind diese um etwa 50.000
und die bischofskonferenz angekündigt
sie wird sich an den oberen grenzen
orientieren
und ich glaube es wurde kürzlich
gemeldet dass 1,9 millionen bereits
schon in den letzten jahren gezahlt
worden sind
professor sternberg gestatten uns noch
eine ganz kurze schlusskurve sg steht
immer die frage im raum ob kirche reform
kann stichwort synodaler weg was muss
passieren dass diese debatte innerhalb
des synodalen weges die angefangen wurde
keine schaufensterveranstaltung bleibt
ja das ist für uns die ganz ganz
wichtige frage und ich denke das ist
auch etwas das deutlich macht dass sie
willig der wille da ist die probleme
anzugehen dass wir die synodalen weg
reformen aufgreifen die systemische
ursachen etwa die das machtgefälle auch
dieses unklare macht verständnis
gewaltenteilung und ähnliches
thematisieren und daran arbeiten und das
wird im synodalen weg mit beschlüssen
und voten passieren und zwar mit
beschlüssen die hier in deutschland
unmittelbar umsetzbar sind mit voten die
eine genehmigung durch rom haben müssen
weil wir weltkirche sind und keine
nationalkirche und es wird auch
beschlüsse geben wie so weitreichend
sind dass sie wahrscheinlich an einem
konzert zu richten sind das so wie ich
das einschätzen immer dringlicher wird
bei fragen die weltweit im moment
diskutiert werden
im phoenix tagesgespräch war dass
professor thomas sternberg präsident des
zentralkomitees der deutschen katholiken
zdk vielen dank nach münster danke da
muss schon auch